[Music]
welcome to viewers Choice everybody
we're starting early I don't know okay
so I'm going to look at two and/or three
games today from the viewers the first
one is from club member Orlando who's
not here that's weird and he sent me
several pages of one game I did a lot of
work and actually at some point in the
game he said Sara Juan says this and
Sara once is that so
I guess he analyzed the game of Sara lon
yeah okay so this is our land overs if
Matthew manly well I'm sure you all know
like you know and that's about it
and then manually is 1525 plus tax and
Orlando was fourteen hundred plus tax
and our Lando's white and this was
played at the Missouri open December
11th
two days after Toni Rich's birthday
coincidentally two days after Nakamura's
birthday okay
so Orlando played efore and they played
a Carroll con now as all of you know
there was a game played two days ago
possibly yesterday between Norway and
Russia in the world team championship
the Norwegian played here which I've
seen lately and the Russian played here
okay and then I was like is this my
chest cam for is this the world
championship for now I couldn't tell
and then black one eventually Orlando's
game didn't go that way okay that's a
true story okay instead they played like
normal people so they must be lower
rated and then he five was played for Al
and I remember Orlando
played the advanced variation of the
Carroll con against Arjun on Saturday
and was crushing Arjun and lost so I
guess he always plays the advanced
variation now who can raise their hand
and tell me the two most common losses
for black you with the right answer
correct and I've played them both and
here Matthew played the one that's less
popular c5 exactly like white also moved
his point again in fact I believe
neither player who how the minor pieces
moved so that's why the game went like
this I was proven to be correct next to
move now c3 is an unusual move which I
faced once and it was in a blitz game
here at the club and my opponent was
Nigel short then he played c3 and beat
me although c3 is not a good move but in
a blitz gain anything is good g c5 is a
common move nothing wrong with that and
I've played c4 in this position because
I also don't know how the minor pieces
move and I bead I think no one Hendrix
in but now it could have been somebody
else I just beat no one Hendrix and so
off I just say it's probably right ok so
he played c3 so as Grand Minister Ken
West pointed out to his chagrin black
has wasted a tempo with C 65 and as a
result if this was an advanced French
defense black spot would already be on
e6
but since the pawns 96 he has an
opportunity to move his bishop probably
to h3 sheer out of style did you get
that at home at least okay okay so now
black proves you knew how the pieces
moved 96 and here Orlando wrote that his
next move is inaccurate or as the
Germans would say inelegant so he thinks
Bishop e3 is correct because you want to
stop your opponent from pinning your
knight since your Knights not there that
would be a bad move okay I guess I agree
somewhat so Knight f3 was played but
traded on d4 which normally we don't
want to play too early because it gives
white the chance to play Knight c3 which
is illegal with a pawn on c3 in fact in
a lot of openings where White's playing
C 3 and then d4 which sounds good
you can't play Knight c3 due to its
illegality
but if they're going to trade on g4 then
you got everything now having said that
I mean at some point why it's going to
take upon a B up upon so yeah okay so he
traded that maybe you should play Bishop
g4 first I don't know and here
Bishop g4 is the normal move and was
recommended by Orlando and he wrote
Bishop f5 was actually played okay now
when I teach chess to my private
students I often explain to them that
when the Queen Bishop moves out often b7
is weak and we can try to punish black
and when you don't move your bishop out
your bishop never moves so basically you
should stop playing chess it's too hard
okay that Mario was complaining earlier
that and you were there
collinear I think he's saying that his
white square bishop is often not very
good and I didn't have the heart to tell
him the truth okay so which was a lot
more than what he said okay so white
tried to punish black immediately and
played Queen b3 with the idea of Queen
b7 and Orlando wrote he thinks blacks
should play Queen d7 here defending his
pawn okay and his opponent played rook
b8 and he thought the rook was strange
on b8
yeah I agree okay you with some crazy
comment yes 96 is actually best because
it moves illegally and confuses your
opponent yeah I know what you meant okay
Knight a5 is legal but you won't know if
it's good that's beyond my understanding
I mean I don't want my knight on a five
by okay it stops Queen takes b7 if I
checked you and you played Queen d7 you
would hang your knight if you played
Bishop d7 you would hang this pawn king
g7 g illegal that 96 would lose your
pawn again so I don't know probably not
right for luck probably okay rook b8 is
not we want your rook but its life
Knight c3 makes sense
make sense Bishop e2 makes sense
most weaker players like you guys like
to play here and trade off you're good
bishop good job okay
don't do that alright Bishop e2 Knight
ge7 it's a little cramped here for black
now in the short caro-kann which this is
looking like and I'll explain what that
is so in the advanced caro-kann if you
played Bishop f5 which is the normal
move and you were playing chess to the
1970s and 1980s then your ganas went
like this then around 1995
nobody did this anymore I actually don't
know why so probably if you do that with
a white you're probably like what if you
memorize every game for the 1990s you'd
win okay um Nigel short never did that
he played Knight f3 and then he played
Bishop e2 and then he castled
and that was called the short variation
because he played at every game and
everybody else was playing g4 and f4 and
h4 and moving your arms loudly okay and
then one of the ideas that black had was
to put the knight here eventually and
then if you move the bishop to either
efore or g4 one of these squares then
then you're going to go to f5 okay or
you could play nine eight six I can't
take it back Wow so yeah so this
position actually reminds me of that
this reminds me of the short variation
because why play Bishop f5 and yeah yeah
and basically blacks take it on d4 very
early this could actually come from the
short variation this would come from
this Bishop f5 I move three okay so
weaker players like to play Knight g6
and lose their Bishop on f5 and have
their knight attacked some stronger
players will play Knight c8 and Knight
b6 and some will move their Bishop to
somewhere and then play Knight f5 so
we'll see what happened I didn't know I
remember I'm old okay Bishop g5 then the
Knights probably not moving and he wrote
a long note White's reluctance to
position his
Bishop on e3 will soon turn into a piece
of driftwood well Sara Juan was critical
of my choice insisting Bishop III was
better okay
guy I guess um yeah yeah probably of all
the plums on the board this D for puns
the weakest because another pawn can't
defend it and it's already being
attacked so Bishop III would defend it
more Bishop g5 is going to get harassed
so I don't know if that's the safest
okay age six was played then he played
Bishop h4 question mark according to him
although I would assume if somebody
played Bishop g5 they wouldn't change
their mind what people do okay now
Orlando writes black should play g5 and
Bishop g7 that makes sense to me got all
his pieces out the bishop on g3 is not
very active this can't move so I agree
with that instead black didn't do that
black played a6 I probably wouldn't have
considered so okay then castles okay now
the next move he doesn't say it's bad
but I don't like it and he said g5 is
the best with similar play to last
variation black played a move that I
tell my students never to play with in
openings where there's no C pawns like
here he played Queen c7 now the purpose
is to unpin the night I guess but the
Queen othersí file will get harassed by
a look so I don't like that square for
my queen um if I played a six I guess
that's why you played a six so I can't
play Knight d5 later right if he plays
Queen to d7 and a white knight comes to
b6 or c5 that could be annoying and
white play Queen B one
okay I mean the Queen sort of done this
job on b3 it's not going to attack
anything else Knight g6 bishop g3 looks
good to me and we turned the page okay
Bob Segar style or as the kids of the
chess camp would say who won get in the
chest kid never heard of anybody I
couldn't in anybody I'm like do you know
iris and she's like no I'm like that's
you and she's like what
never heard nobody okay so Bishop e7
this should be so it's Bishop g3 okay
then Bishop e7 Rick c1 as I indicated
the black queen isn't really well placed
here because of the rook and I guess
black agreed because black played Queen
to d8 so these guys are better than me
they play Queen d1 and Queen via they
retreat more than I do
motivated by a concern about the
imminent advance of the white pawn to h4
and h5 Wow more than white playing Rick
c1 which is play tricks t1 I mean he
might be right that that's why black
should do it but anything black was
thinking about h4 h5 when white played
Rick c1 that's the kind of people I play
so yeah Queen v8 sort of does double
duty then it avoids the rook and it
defending h4 so we don't get harassed
all right Bishop d3 which we normally
don't want to play but he pled anyway
because he thought I didn't know what
else to do gotta do something it's hard
for whites of movies pieces anywhere and
they traded on d3 I believe yep and like
finally castled
so so far nobody's hung all their pieces
what kind of game is this
don't worry I have a game somebody sent
me and we're back on track and I wasn't
I wouldn't look at the game normally
because every move is not good but the
guy wrote like something funny at the
beginning in a preamble so then I was
like alright that's good enough for me
92 okay that's that's a chess move not
one I would make Knight d4
he says that's bad
you should play b6 a Queen b6 first get
b6 yeah okay Queen b6 makes him sense
that puts pressure on White's pond but
he played night before that we call that
a Ken West move I never would have
called that a Ken West move before today
but we were looking at puzzles earlier
you know Grand Master's of the chess
club like a look at puzzles me and Ken
West and he suggested a move and I said
why did you make that movie he said he
detects something
so that's 94 checks to things that's so
amazing
okay so white could play clean b3 or
queen b 1e chose b1 he wanted to retreat
so I agree and then he kicked out the
night and the night we treated now the
players drew by repetition white played
a 2 and black played Knight d4 and so
forth oh and he can't do that now white
played rook c3 I assumed two double
rooks wow that worked disappeared maybe
I was wrong I guess I was incorrect yes
he'll did it all right and it says this
is no good I'm the worst so he doesn't
like his own move now you'll remember
earlier black played Queen g8 and he
explained that was to prevent h4 even
though white jazz plays rook c1 so I
don't believe that but blacks Queen is
not on g8 anymore which sort of proves
you never saw each ball coming and so he
says I should play h4 h5 rawr okay if
you play h5 Black's gonna play Knight h8
or hang apiece equally likely in this
club and I like to play 9 h8 so I'd be
pretty happy all right and yeah I agree
with h4 that sounds reasonable
okay Rick c3 to me looks reasonable I
wouldn't complain about that okay Rick
CA Rick c1
I've never seen such a good game this
looks like to GMs are playing you know
not good GM's like British gems okay now
Knight a5 and now he gives himself
another question mark and I agree Trey
Ken West approves though because he
attacked the night so that's kind of
like way outside tonight okay now when
black played 9 c4 make
for when black played Knight a5 he
probably had two ideas trade all the
rooks because people like to trade for
some reason and play Knight c4 because
the Knights been on c4 and at some point
if black does play nine c4
probably later in the game white could
play b3 maybe not now but maybe sometime
in soon right especially if white was
kappa blanka you got that no sometimes
soon and soon no this is what I deal
with here they don't know the movie
Casablanca and they don't put cap they
don't do nothing I did it it seems we're
not familiar with puns
we shall not move along to the next rule
okay so why play d4 and now Knight c4
it's hard to attack the knight with a
plot unless you cheat or you're playing
bughouse so would you put all your puns
on one color which both sides did then
the other color sort a week now the
difference is white played Bishop d3
earlier and traded his white squared
bishop so when white put all of his
funds on one color which used to be
darkened now is green then he would like
a white squared bishop to control the
other color which he traded conversely
blacks pawns are all on white squares
and so he has a dark squared Bishop so
he's happy controlling the dark squares
so if y could cheat and play Knight c5
which is the equivalent of blacks 94 not
only can later black play b6 maybe not
now but sometime and soon you'll regret
it no yeah you have a while I could talk
to
I get more feedback oh okay that wall
has people on it okay so there was a
dark squared bishop and the possibility
of b6 and the fact that 95 is incredibly
illegal this seems like black is doing
well because the vision on G 3 is a
little suspicious okay so this looks
nice 9 c4
uh now he played rook 1c - maybe he
wants to alaka'i and gun it maybe uh
maybe he did so I'll be right yeah he
did okay now he doesn't like blacks next
to move he says blacks should play a
five attacking the Queen side I agree
but he played b5 solidifying his Knight
but she doesn't like but I like that too
and then queen c1 as I suggested okay
and then black moved his night away and
hung all his rooks now that's what you
would do now he writes a5 is still
stronger I agree
a5 puts tremendous pressure on blacks
and whites Queen side yeah I agree
and he played rook c6 I guess he wants
to do the same thing white did now
luckily there's another side of the
board otherwise this game would be sort
of boring and white played h4 now we're
talking yeah yeah now we play h5 we can
you know do get some pressure going
Knight f4 and then he wrote at last okay
and I make a joke but you we can get it
so okay so h5 was given as better by the
annotator and but he played Queen to d8
and now black claimed to draw because he
played Queen D at three times and
unfortunately dr. Morris was the arbiter
so you were here for that I mean there
was a huge argument in the club last a
few days ago and they didn't agree what
happened so I they wanted my ruling and
I said you guys don't agree what
happened why I could rule while you said
it what you said but there could be
different ruling yeah yeah one guy was
like I made the same move three times to
draw and then the guy said what and then
they argued about that they were both
wrong - that was my ruling you're both
wrong that seems the most likely okay h5
now you know me I like to retreat but
Knight age 4 is not a retreat so he
played that well that move smells a
little cuz it's been aged for who
brought the cricket okay now it wasn't
really a cricket it was a cricket phone
which is work even less
but a cricket whoo-hoo yeah you sure
yeah there we go
yeah are you are you a new member now
which smells worse NH 4 NH 3 yeah that's
what I was thinking yeah
that's why the does nobody played at age
3 we don't me to do I got to make
whatever joke I can ok
so what did I do
ok so clean f4 dubious according to the
player with white he doesn't like his
own moves
white insists on keeping his septic
bishop board on g3 Wow I did write that
also English as a second language so
that's pretty good surprisingly enough
this very bad Bishop is about to become
the protagonist of whites resurrection
on the Kings side so he's complaining he
should have traded his bishop they says
it was grade I don't know his indolence
so I'm guessing he's saying he should
take that because his bishop isn't too
good here ok I guess I'd work f3 I just
did a Jonathan trance there
I played Queen after without looking at
the score I just had a mission with him
where he pre-move dand that wasn't the
labor
now we're threatening here now his
comments make a lot of sense now Queen
need to understand now he's claiming
white should play here but white
retreated I can't complain about
retreating and then he went back FC
three okay no yeah okay now black made a
bad move
a five is still the best move according
to him and I assume he analyzed with
yessir so one time ago but well now he
did the Popeye attack which I just made
up as I was saying it he got all he
could stands he can't stands the war
they did a lot of maneuvering around and
he looked at his watch is like time to
lose because earlier in the game nobody
blundered anything or did anything so
you guys were bored that means it's a
good game and blacks black that's enough
of that
so he plays the most exciting move right
do you guys find an exciting move for
black that doesn't lose all his pieces
there's a lot of exciting was the do
lose all your pieces the one that just
like doesn't lose anything but it's
exciting
f5 yeah you're the man that's what he
did I guess he wants to take that okay
and f5 is exciting so I could take on
four son but he didn't he played Bishop
f4 and he writes I was tempting black to
do this so black did do that which I
think I would you too then he sac
everything to make it really exciting
for you guys and then after here he
played Bishop h6 X climb according to
him okay and he might be right because
blacks pieces are all on the queenside
so if I take with a queen and I got
Knight f4 and rook g3 yeah even this
work could get into the fun so he was
hoping black would take that pawn so he
could start attacking and sacrificing
okay
so now according to the annotator black
should have played the brilliant Knight
takes e5 confusing everyone a likely
continuation would be let me the rooks
hanging on c2 so okay now the Queen is
hanging so these would make sense now
the Knights hanging so Knight g6 now the
Queen is hanging so Queen b8 check now
all of whites pieces are hanging his
queen is bishop so he goes Queen g3
attacking this Knight and he says during
the game I missed everything
luckily for me so did my opponent yeah
the truth hurts
and he says wife's down upon but has
compensation yes sir probably likes
black because white blacks up upon okay
well Knight takes e5 is an interesting
tactic uh you know discovered attack on
the rook okay instead black played my
favorite move how my kid was do I have
the ship FA defense I can't complain
about that you know what's wrong
Queen g5 and I was telling a student
this
I won't say which one because I'll tell
you like it a month-and-a-half there's a
reason why I want to tell you now and I
said sometimes when you're attacking and
it doesn't work it works anyway so yeah
this apply could be a good example this
game does a lot of times when you're
attacking the engine says Oh easy
defense then the human you're playing
gets mated so ken west that whatever
happened to him
never okay so he claims Knight takes e5
is still the best and then he gives very
long variation rook takes rook Knight
takes rook he just winds upon but
instead he played rook here defending
the second-ranked even more like attack
with another piece more if he would be
proud a lot of pieces attacking and now
he he says black makes another bid if
all your moves are bad you might lose
right plays here and now he plays a
brilliant tactical shot let me even sure
if I like it but he likes it so no okay
he played here Rahr Rahr in black took
and now black didn't take the bishop he
writes if if king takes bishop 96-97
White's better okay I don't know maybe
maybe not I have advice for my students
when you can take a bishop take it
that's my vice so I would take that
bishop and if the computer said I was
losing I would still take the bishop but
he defended his e pawn I don't agree
with that is it white a pawn up now
right so I would take the bishop because
then I wouldn't be down upon my
reasoning okay now X clam rook cc3 and
now the taking the bishop loses now he
took it and he writes that suicidal but
doesn't give it a question mark because
he wanted to win he writes the best to
move his Bishop g5 x coin
and then he gives insane position
analysis but now he takes it because he
defended against 96 he was all happy and
then they agreed to it now rook check
King moves rook check that's exciting
Keeney eight rook check King g7 double
up on the bubble up rook e8 Knight G 696
desk exclamation mark was there another
move that you would ever consider as I
consider Knight h5 and go here but IG
six without thinking yeah um he took
this very important pawn lead on I was
kidding
that that doesn't seem very helpful now
do you think white should trade rooks or
not trade rooks what do you think yeah
cuz waiting the guy's easier when you
have more looks yeah so 97 rookie 7 and
I'd rather resign resigning was better
then work here threatening to different
checkmates
and black resigned while black took that
bishop when white was meeting him
instead of taking it when he was like at
an endgame that was to be struck so that
wasn't good defense but he had a good
excuse he claims they were both in time
trouble so yeah that was an interesting
game because it actually went the way it
was supposed to go this opening normally
White's attacking on the Kings side and
blacks plating on the Queen side and
that's what happened and then according
to Bobby Fischer you made the guys
better than winning on the Queen side
right but the Fischer was crazy so maybe
he's wrong well you can be crazy and
right - right
well I he's claiming that White has a
better endgame but I'm not sure I agree
because I'm old like he likes white here
and then he actually gave some move King
g8 oh if I play King g8 but okay
and he says here White's better because
it looks like this pawn is a week right
but if my King could go to e6 or g6 that
would be better right so I'm not sure I
agree with King g8
I think I agree with it at all okay so
yeah this is what should have happened
then you know he might like put the game
in if he didn't win so it's good that
this happened but yeah I would never I
would never not take the bishop and then
take it when the guys meeting me that
seems like a bad idea
yeah but they were in time trouble so
okay so that game was our club member
Orlando who's been all my lectures
except this one where I showed his game
but I'll show somebody I'm not sure who
so that was a good game
thank you pretty good okay I don't like
good games I liked again we're looking
at now okay and definitely looking at
this one this is my favorite game so the
guy writes bla bla bla bla bla
this game will force Feingold to flip
the board which is a nice bonus so let's
flip the board yeah because if my comer
shows up he'll be like wait what's going
on here okay then he writes a lot of
other stuff and if you remember our
lesson jacooz yeah we talked about this
like exactly what happens and then the
guy sends in a game so maybe it's you
maybe it's you know by the way the game
won and what we talked about we talked
about the Icelandic ambit yeah okay so
that's where you win the World
Championship and Iceland and go there to
die that's a splendid gambit recommended
by there you go you guys under someone
as you look or seem to be your best
tests indicate okay so the game went for
d5 takes here as discussed yeah okay now
he doesn't say what the Icelandic gambit
is or he didn't I didn't read it
which is
equally likely but he means after c4 the
old move was c6 and then everybody plays
the pan off with white and some people
who can pay off kill Khan and some
people play Knight c3 and then do this
and this is also interesting
okay but the Icelandic gambit which was
invented about 20 years ago is e 6 and
now if white wants to he can transpose
into an exchange French with c4 by
playing this and that's considered to be
nothing for white or he could take a
pawn which is usually how you play chess
you take pawn and a lot of people who
play gambits
like this position for black and people
who like to accept gamble it's like it
for white therefore it's equal okay so
this is a very interesting gambit but
there's not a lot of super gem games
anyway he was hoping to do that
his opponent played Knight c3 which is
legal
barely and after this white plated move
I've never seen before and I've been
watching chests for a long time I've
seen Queen f3 I've seen 94 but the name
was Bishop c4 it that's what you know it
in budge house this is very common and
then you play you play g4 here okay
there's a common bughouse position but
he played Knight g5 which I don't know
because white has nothing developed now
so that's weird okay and after d4 black
played very aggressive 'if I've I'm not
sure if I would play that but if that
probably wouldn't I'd probably play
knight c6 okay so he took I'm not sure
if I would take the Queen or the pawn
took the pawn I don't know
I mean quickie to is obviously equal but
white played for the advantage and black
played Bishop b4 check which is very
interesting because it looks like c3 you
can take it but I don't think you can
take it so if that's the case this
should be for check is pretty silly
because I could play c3 and then you if
you try to like fork like king and rook
I go here so
Oh so I if the game had gone c3 maybe he
wouldn't have said the game end
or maybe he would have won another
brilliant way and I tell all my
beginning students which are about the
same level as you guys if your opponent
can check you or if you could check
somebody they block with a pawn and then
you move it away like don't do that even
though in the Scotch we do that
sometimes but you guys don't know that
so I don't like this should be for check
okay white play Bishop d2 which is not
good and black could have taken on b2
but he was probably worried about his
King on e8 probably shouldn't be worried
about it cuz you can castle next move so
he castled and Knight f3 and now you
take on b2 because that's why you played
Bishop before check I think and it's a
pawn and it's hanging but he played here
much worse things happen later these are
the kind of games I prefer the last one
this game just don't make a lot of sense
okay
White Castle defending his B pawn and
now he played Queen d2 and white thought
it was made so he gave up no none of
that happened but in my camp it happened
every game and it'll happen next week at
my camp yes also for those of you who
watch a lot of my videos it'll happen in
the one o'clock class every so this
should have five that's legal Bishop d3
is legal Bishop e6 because he likes to
lose Bishop a lot don't really
understand that Knight g5 threatening h7
Bishop f5 so yeah that's that you can
see why he submitted the game ticket
Muse you guys okay what's funny is there
was a game that I show a lot between
Morphy and doofus Murphy's black and in
the opening early middle game white
plays Knight g5 Bishop d3 and black
plays Bishop f5 stopping h7 threat so
I'm here blackness Bishop every move but
more if he did a once okay and then
Bishop c4 which I think I agree with
maybe 96 and
very unusual thing to do moving a piece
that hasn't moved yet
I'm very confused where kg 195 now we're
talking move the piece that just moved
okay now some very very very suspicious
things happened which is funny for us I
don't even know who's better here
probably black well I don't know okay
played b3 and I want to explain
something to you guys don't play b3 did
you did you did you understand not
playing b3 so I mean this should be
three makes a lot more sense the
Bishop's attacked b3 doesn't really
defend the bishop and I have a rule for
my students who play b3 and G 3 and B 6
and g6 you have to put a bishop there so
what white should have done after b3 is
put a bishop on b2 that's what he should
have done but that's not legal
she'll should have done it there's
pieces everywhere here so you could find
a bishop on any board right okay don't
be confused the players aren't good Rick
where you're talking about earlier
you're talking about now yeah yeah
Claudio thinks we should play rook e5
Queen e5 Knight f3 Knight takes Queen
and then I guess I'd move my queen I
don't know where I'd move it somewhere
f6 that's somewhere but Claudia wants me
to do this because Claudia wants to do
that and everybody clap so let's go clap
Claudia Claudia
he didn't suggest Queen da but he meant
to after this you're going to clap less
but that's too bad yeah and I still
think this is probably good for why I'm
not stood for black isn't it and even
your brilliance he didn't work come on
okay so yeah but anyway if that worked
they wouldn't see that even want to you
know at the end they wouldn't see it
okay so you played b3 confusing
audience okay I'm not confused because I
teach chess camp a lot so that's never
was legal that confuses me so b3 is one
of the worst moves ever because the
black queen can you know take advantage
of that okay but we're not done by a
long shot
both sides were winning later and the
game was two moves along and I'm not
kidding it's all true
they're all lies but they're
entertaining lines and in the end isn't
that the real truth the answer is no
okay
so h6 was played which is funny because
I think that also wins because I'm a
threatening okay white played 94
attacking the black queen with check
pausing for a fact that neither players
seem to notice that because now black
played the move that was given earlier
Knight takes e4 so it seems to me Knight
takes Queen check would be reasonable
and then white would win and then black
wouldn't send the game end but he took
back and then he played bass on I took
the night I'm sorry yeah what am I crazy
yeah he took the night and then he
played mate and in the notes to the game
he didn't really mention that part like
the last form was weren't talked about
he was like in the opening what yeah I
can but it's not easy
yeah well it wasn't my game yeah so yeah
something so white didn't take a queen
with Shaq and black didn't play mate in
one here he took the night and then he
played mate one okay and that was the
game that was submitted you don't want
to see the games he didn't submit that
was were not at that level
okay I like that game I normally
wouldn't show it but he wrote a funny
preamble so I had to show it yeah I
looked at another game but I mean I
would go ahead I was getting sick so
let's look at a game I didn't rated
blitz game
ah ah also these are the games John
Schrank said were the best he didn't put
the other games in so that was one of
the better games because he that I
didn't do it yeah a 20-6 moved wha who
would submit that why let's find out I
played against the wim I got a winning
position and blundered into a draw
alright let's have a look yeah I
remember John said this wasn't the best
game of all time I think it was the
second best game of all time so he was
white had to flip the board again and
yeah it gives you perfect game okay so
it was a Sicilian the submitter is white
but he drew see he didn't submit okay
I've had this position today I was
playing a blitz game with former US
Champion Stuart Rachel's and I played he
six but this guy played Bishop g7 which
is also a move f4 is legal rook c8 is
the point of Bishop d7 okay Queen d2 and
now you take the knight and whites play
Queen d2 and Queen before we have five
yeah this is black is playing normal
here
okay now white played very aggressively
re5 our day and then takes takes as
dangerous for both sides
um I mean off the top of my head 94
looks interesting and of Queeny for work
c3 at Bishop d2 probably wins so I
resigned
okay so Knight g4 and now he did a what
do you call it interference although it
looks like he didn't know he did
interference
yeah e6 I guess if you play Bishop e6
Bishop b5 check is annoying right so she
took with the F pawn I would probably
take this and I assume the only reason
not to take it is Rick c3 and then I
don't know what's happening here I have
Queen e5 check here okay so that's
probably okay for black so he played h4
recommended by Arjen
okay then 'if I've defending the knight
h6 takes tank so this seems like blacks
upon up and better although he was
claiming I got a winning position well
not here alrighty six castles looks good
this should be four looks good Negi for
looks interesting clean a tree looks
good
Knight d6 looks interesting if I move my
king I'm threatening Queen a one mate
right so I guess I'd would like him not
sure where King seven Knight takes rook
takes I follow it by King e7 because
that green one may it looks pretty good
okay
he took which looks okay also so blacks
up two pawns and black and white hasn't
moved these pieces yet so I would assume
this is good for black King e7 he takes
e5 were caged e8 you can't take this
pawn because they work singing and play
Bishop to b5
like I can't take the rook I mean I can
take the rook so I what if I take the
rook what am I missing as usual also
this just wins immediately right that
looks good
and this looks good well it all looks
good to me
white might have a perpetual but I doubt
it so okay so I like black bit of what
black does black play Bishop b5 rook da
Rick da Queen g7 and I guess if I go to
the D file I could check of wing this
rook so the game ended like this and
then draw but I don't understand the
preamble which says I got a winning
position and blundered into a draw it
wasn't white always worse I didn't put
an engine on it so but I didn't ever
like White's position ever I like that I
move one or two then after that I didn't
like it so much so it seems like black
was winning and and the bishops AG drew
because what black didn't play correctly
so I'll change the preamble slightly
yeah
that's why wim that wgm and I have like
three or four jokes I can't make any of
them because he might not edit them out
that I'll get in trouble
experience or not I can make them but
you you might not ended it out and then
I yeah so I'm not gonna make those jokes
okay but they're good jokes don't
frickin there's some good jokes yeah all
right now what's happening leaving at
7:00 what's this picture okay it's a
picture yeah so since I'm catching a
flight at 727 we're going to end the
class am i catching a flight Arjun
correct
very good did you bring cake cat good
answer I didn't expect that and my last
question before the class ends is what
skid cap backwards now you're talking
all right and on that note with Arjun
giving the correct answers
submit games you could send them to Ben
Simon @b up now I'm kidding you go to
info at st. Louis chess club org really
random guess if you could submit games
and then I won't look at them okay
although I will look at the next week
but not the following week it'll be
looked at by Josh freed oh yeah so
there's one more week I'm doing this
great class ow
those air quotes really hurts your
fingers and then this is this is a funny
day Thursday who knows what day it is
where you are but I teach this class and
then we do games you shouldn't learn by
heart these are games you should forget
by heart usually make sure you forget it
otherwise you'll have guys that I lost
cuz I remember that game you know I mean
keep saying the games and good job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]